who's this interesting alpha I inquired  of Monsieur Jean to my surprise he was  distinctly taken aback don't you know he  asked don't you recognize him he did  look familiar that's mr. Moustafa  himself he arrived early this morning  this name will no doubt be familiar to  the more seasoned persons among you  mister zero Moustafa was at one time  the richest man is a broker and was  still indeed the owner of the grand  Budapest he often comes and stays a week  or more three times year at least but  never in the season Monsieur Jean  signaled to me and I leaned closer I'll  tell you a secret  he takes only a single bed sleeping room  without a bath in the rear corner of the  top floor and it's smaller than the  service elevator